e os irmãos cabelo hein ao Submisso
recorta ao máximo de assumir-se na Vila
dos irmãos capilar O que será que o dia
reserva para estes irmãos e
e esse é o problema sempre trago à 7:15
nunca consigo pagar antes do tempo sério
isso meu cabelo Geralmente eu só consigo
carregar a parte tentar dormir um pouco
para ver se ela vai passar logo
[Música]
G1
E aí
o step é de madeira Esquenta da hora mas
eu tô dois mesmo é que de 7 horas
Oi oi tá então a água do chuveiro cai na
cabeleira cachoeira me chamou a gente
para assistir isso Oxe tu tá rindo rapaz
É mas ele riu de sua Carlos deles mesmo
que sacar mas tá certo eu mandava que eu
mais gosto eu acho que eu chamei você
você não quis ir contigo mas eu espero
que eu acho que é só um cara muito
difícil e tu não é de que site que é
engraçado né Tu não tá achando engraçado
não
Se vocês gostam Engraçado eu vi mesmo
machucando as coisas mais engraçados eu
assisti toda né não sério mesmo acho que
leva a mal não não vi nenhum momento
ainda não não sei se é porque tá no
mesmo assim meu amigo fosse primeiro ou
segundo você chuva pela Esse é o erro eu
prefiro ver Malhação a chance de dar o
play que é melhor que o outro nós faz
vai duas um irmão Oi irmão cabelo eu já
estou indo pelo amor de Deus que tá
acontecendo nada não era só para te
desejar um bom dia você já tomou café
aqui em casa o negócio tá difícil não
tem nada para você
a Carol mesmo cabelo Acertou em cheio é
da Coité da seu mais gosta pega de volta
sua vaca irmão e
o direto da Bahia João cabelo Você tá
ficando cada dia Maria a
Oi bom dia irmão cabelo Bom dia Bom dia
irmão cabelo aí meu cabelo tem alguma
coisa diferente em você e
e não é o seu cordão Cadê o seu portão e
não cabelo Ei cara no meu corpo tão cara
e você quer meu cordão irmão irmão
cabelo seu corda não é seu como é que eu
vi não vi não será que não perdeu
surfando só eu sabia que não podia só
falar com os Bodyboard dois eu sabia que
não podia confiar no Jack para
firmemente onde só tem direita eu não
posso confiar em quem só chuva para a
direita eu quero achar meu cartão cara
não cabelo não fica assim mexeu com o
irmão cabelo mexeu com todos irmãos
cabelo é verdade o irmão cabelo
se você tem certeza que não viu nada mas
eu vou perguntar para o final do me ver
eu acho que ele deve saber tudo bem tudo
bom
o meu cabelo é isso tem que falar com
ele aqui eu falei meu cabelo dizendo que
a gente toma também tem nenhuma aqui é
cordão masha vai explicar Qual a cor do
negócio eleição o irmão cabelo um
acordou e o outro irmão cabelo tá do
outro lado sentiu foto do cordão do
irmão cabelo que acordou do outro lado
tentar de Neve tipo assim eles são muito
unidos né E aí eles se conhecem assim
não muito mais ponto que tipo ele viu
que tava faltando um cordão do que o
cara mais amava e aí avisou para ele aí
nesse momento se criou o conflito da
série entendeu não acha que vocês não
presta atenção uma toda a vida a mesma
coisa narrador falou no começo ócio era
bons Capela ai ou só meus ocorre a voz
depois a do narrador da mesma agave aí ó
Ai meu Deus você só fala depois que eu
ligo para ela agora nós tem que achar
esse cordão que se a mamãe chegar e ver
que nós lutar com nossos cordão ela vai
bater e nós todinho né só em você não é
E aí
eu vou marcar você deve pela sua escada
que eu deixo pela minha que nós se
encontra ali embaixo oh tia será que
aconteceu concordam que o irmão cabelo
estou preocupado Será que eles vão
encontrar você
o seu cordão por bem ou por mal ai ai ai
ai uma farta meu dedo irmão mas isso não
vai ser nem preciso que eu acabar com
ele já tô indo irmão o meu irmão eu já
tô indo na boca os irmãos cabelo então
dão início à procura do cordão te
retículo não tem nada em é bem difícil
de seguir mas eu consigo cuidado cuidado
cuidado Se você morrer eu vou perder meu
emprego e
e vai seu cair meu cabelo mas não tem
nada lá em cima não vamos procurar os
irmãos cabelo estão fazendo de tudo para
encontrar este Portal foi uma coisa aí
eu acho que dentro de mim
bom então desce aqui é perigoso irmão
beleza e
Oi querido Ei tu é doido mesmo Ei que
que tu tá fazendo aí irmão irmão cabelo
Você viu o tamanho nesse coloquei não
aqui que tem aqui não tem prestar
atenção nele falta uns cocão dito demais
os cookies desse gigantesca A mamãe
disse que é dos maiores coco e faz
melhor água a mamãe sempre falava isso
né ela tem que falava Mamãe eu tô
falando tá pegando tá olhando esse aqui
tá falando que é bonita você achou foi
então não achei ainda não né achei que
tava no coqueiro Mas então tenho certeza
irmão que falou os irmãos mais não
corresponde ao número ainda não daí que
nossa casa então tá com ele vamos pegar
ele ouve uma três deles vem fazer umas
cabelo procuram de lá procuram de carro
procurando ali procuram da pular e até
agora nada de encontrar esse cordão e
[Música]
o Thiago tá um pouco salgado mas eu não
comprei nada ainda não e você meu cabelo
o que é que foi eu vou acionar por aí
não velho eu não tava procurando nada tá
fazendo o quê aí eu entrei na piscina
para mijar todo mundo olha que nojo do
nego irmão deixar que eu vou achar esse
cordão agora vou procurar um pouco mais
beleza beijo cuida mesmo tô sentindo
falta do Wagner ai caraca tô parando rir
enquanto isso do outro lado tá fila pois
éramos cabelo tentam desvendar o que
ainda não foi desvendado o cabelo eu
tenho passado mais hidratante da minha
pele ultimamente ver como tá sendo o
nosso está macia e sedosa olha parece
que estão passando uma novo para
conhecer a gente não gosta dessas coisas
você falou não falou com o final do me
falei falei igual o macho macho macho
debaixo do tomate mas dessa história
está ficando muito sem pé e sem cabeça
irmão cabelo meu cabelo oi oi
a conta Fiquei sabendo que os irmãos
bole-bole e
eu estou na praia uma hora dessa e mais
ou menos depois da casa do Tonho graxa
eu não gosto eu também meu irmão ele faz
péssimos para iniciantes gratis é que
tem um Antônio pão de mel que trabalha
na oficina e tem outro graxa da padaria
então que eu vou gostar é o mesmo Abrir
música notícia eu falei antes dele
viajar a trabalho e os irmãos que podem
estar envolvido nisso podem não
e vamos irmãos e tem que enfrentar os
seus medos não sei mas eu já falei que
eu não gosto de morar em borda velho Aí
você gosta do seu cordão ou não gosta
nós vamos atrás daquele Cigano o meu
misterioso que mora na praia e
se você já tô perguntando Pode vamos
velho gordão Cigano entendendo mais nada
você pode se a falar mas não sei quantos
minutos nós estamos assistindo vocês não
pegar a história tá acontecendo mas é o
seguinte os irmãos também comprou Aí vou
por aí eles estão juntos o tempo todo só
esse ajuste sumiu cordão de um todos se
uniram para buscar um deles quero mais
esperto que todo mundo fica pensando que
ele anda para lá e para cá aí cadê esse
rapaz aparece ele já foi na casa do
final de bebê começou o final de mim né
estava lá os dois conversando ou Finados
em mim passa as informações o filado
passou as informações aí é coisa de aí
que é nós sempre ele passou as
informações que a pessoa se fosse um
eu não tô entendendo não Google não
significa que essa aí deixa eu explicar
um rapaz volta para informações eu não
sei que ensinado ele também que enfim aí
vai só ter esse episódio assistir os
caras são loucos só postaram esse aí e
como ele volta com as informações aí ele
vai dizer onde é que onde é que tem um
lugar que eles Possivelmente pode como
encontrar esse cordão Ou acha outro
cordão parecido com ele para o irmão não
ficar triste que é aonde lá no Cigano
irmão então a gente vai por onde Vamos
para direita direita contra a esquerda
também pega a vó volta para a direita
que quer saber para frente para frente
para frente para frente para trás para
trança para o pai isso Levanta a
mãozinha e isso bate palminha mais ou
menos é isso que os cara atende isso
volta para a direita digo podem para
esquerda para direita de quem vem tudo
bem
Olá Boa sorte fazer a música Cabelo
então a força dicas valiosas se dirigem
ao seu cabelo morreu em busca de
solucionar o mistério nosso irmão você
deve ter gastado logando um carro vai se
impressionar em saber que eu não gastei
nada eu comprei minhas próprias on
e após quilômetros e quilômetros andando
atrás dos Irmãos Grimm Brothers os
irmãos cabelo então desistem de procurar
os e decidem diretamente aos ignorar
porque não comprar logo esse cordão e
acabar com todo esse mistério Mas será
que ele é só um simples Cigano vendedor
ou será que ele guarda mistérios eu acho
que é
E aí
[Aplausos]
oi oi meu cabelo ele parece ser meio
solitário né vamos ver se eu acho que
vai ter que ir lá e
e o
ou será que o cigano mora nessa casinha
a única que tem nesse local que a gente
veio procurar deve ser irmão
e essa foi com certeza o meu Deus Mike
Então esse é o tão falado Cigano esse
cara não tem cara de vendedor de cordão
E aí
o que aquele Satanás ele mostra muito
semelhante criatura aquela lá em cima
será seu animalzinho de estimação eu
peço que eu tô pintado que coisa
horrível
Olá a todos meu cabelo não tá eu não
usei o negócio da mal não sou irmão
responde daqui não perca o próximo
episódio de irmãos cabelo dele é
e acabou assim troquei com a cara né não
tem seu final teve o final aí mas ele
fica antigo esperando o posto lá e aí eu
usei assim é isso aí eu mandei eles não
acho acho Silvano lacaio uma série série
é composta por episódios ainda volto
segunda não tem ainda não tem que pegar
o Chiquinho e mas os cara quiser são
gênios Mas acho que ele dia é fica
fazendo é toda hora de mão beijada foi
posto em dois anos e o segundo episódio
vai sair daqui daqui que um ano né mas
não meu filho agora qual será o final
dessa história O que será que acontecerá
com os irmãos Capela Qual será o final
deste enredo nesta Trama texto o que
você quiser chamar escreva nos
comentários o que você quer que aconteça
que nós iremos fazer acontecer e quer
dizer só se nós gostarmos Rosa irmãos
cabelo hein
e continua
E aí